[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of what's up
rough hello walter good day how are you i'm
fine i'm glad let's get right into it i'll open
with a word of prayer our heavenly father thank
you so much for bringing us back together we ask
that you please bless once again the discussion
and help us with the holy spirit to discern
the truth from error in jesus name amen amen
before we start i think i would just
like to tell the viewers because some
feel that the information
is of a very negative nature
that the very fact that there is so much negative
information tells us where we are in the stream
of time and that is the good news yes the
good news is that this mess will soon be over
and we must not lose sight of the final
victory of righteousness over unrighteousness
definitely we will also do a whole discussion
yes on that because after all that is what
sustains us exactly we are not sustained
by negative information it's depressing
definitely but if you see it in the light
of the fulfillment of prophecy and you see
that the finish line is just ahead of you it
should actually encourage you in other words
the more negative information there is the closer
we are to the end yes that's the viewpoint that
you have to have the whole time so when you look
and that's even when you when you read a newspaper
when you browse through all these negative
things that's out there you must put it into
prophetic perspective absolutely and you know
where it's heading and that's what i think
we've been trying to do this whole series then
as we said claim the promises claim the promises
definitely yes because we know where we're heading
we don't have a god who is disconnected who
who is not in control because he predicted all of
these things therefore he is absolutely in control
and it is he who decides when he's going to loosen
the winds so that the strife can become even more
yeah it's interesting he's never caught off god
so nothing of this is a surprise to god nothing
he told us beforehand and we just have to put in
the puzzle and see because we know what absolutely
wonderful so today let's discuss some questions
again just to help perhaps we should just say
we get so many questions it's virtually impossible
for us to answer them all definitely i spend quite
a few hours every day just answering questions
and it's a it's a never-ending task because
if you get hundreds of questions and each one
just requires a paragraph even or maybe a page
well that's like writing a book every single day
of your life which is not possible yeah that's
why we also encourage the people to look at the
links that we provide look at the other videos
on the on the site and there's also a lot of
information on the website yes just under that
information section of what the series is about
or this lecture is about click there and there
all the links are there so that should help people
yes and that's also what we do we every now and
then get time to make a questions and answer uh
whatsapp yeah so please look at those that we
don't get repetitive yes and many many answers
to many of the questions are on the web page
in the question and answer section so if they are
there then you know we won't be going into them
okay so let's kick off with the first question
why does the original 1611 king james contain
the apocryphal books well the roman catholic
church had declared the apocryphal books canonical
that means they were part of the canon part
of the bible but let's be quite plain about
it all the apocryphal books were added centuries
after the close of the canon so they are additions
now some of the apocryphal books like maccabees
for example are historic accounts and there's
nothing wrong with an historic account it's
like you know checking out an encyclopedia but
that doesn't mean that it's inspired you don't
need to put it into the canon you can go and
check out historical sources and then verify them
with the bible yes so yes so they included those
but then there are many apocryphal books which
they included which support their doctrines
the veneration of the dead the veneration
of relics and all this hocus-pocus stuff
that is totally out of line with what the
scriptures have to say and we must remember
that all the early reformers were roman catholics
and they were roman catholic priests and prove
truth is progressive and so the original one they
they had them in because they'd always been in
and then they realized but hang on a second
this stuff contradicts the plainest teaching
of the bible and they realized that they
were not canonical and took them out
and rome complained bitterly and declared
an anathema on anyone who does not find them
canonical because i mean i mean worshiping the
top of your staff driving out demons with the gall
bladder of a fish and all kinds of ridiculous
things which are contrary to the scriptures
are in those apocryphal writings so the reformers
as they developed in understanding and in doctrine
realized that these had no place in the bible
and took them out okay thank you okay the next
person asks a few questions what does the
bible and spirit of prophecy have to say
is a woman allowed to have braided hair either
natural or artificial is a woman allowed to wear
pants or trousers are beats allowed to be used in
making a song for worship okay that is a mouthful
and a very sensitive issue to many people
my wife actually wrote an article on dress
you can put a link in there i will and
then people can read that so we don't
have to go into the details of whether pants are
allowable or not the issue is a woman should not
wear what pertaineth to a man and the question
is what does pertaineth to a man actually mean so
read that article and see if you agree or not
there's a lot of latitude as to how people
interpret these things and is a woman allowed to
have braided hair either natural or artificial
what was the issue that is always the question
what was the issue that god was addressing
was he addressing the fact that some women have
braided hair let's say natural hair what does he
want them to do shave it off in other places it
says a woman should not shave her head because
that had to do with pagan worship where that
was a custom as it is in the world today still
yes many religious systems have this uh ideology
that the head should be shaven even in catholicism
and other world religions so what was the issue
the issue was haughtiness the women of zion are
haughty they're full of themselves in other words
they cannot wait to stand in front of the mirror
and braid their hair and uh i always what was the
the method behind it yes why did they want to why
did they want to do it and you know once you start
getting haughty and you think that you're the
bee's knees and you start shaking your head like
that and thinking you're great that's the problem
so natural braided hair is nothing even braided
hair that hasn't anything to do with haughtiness
let's say you have a very special occasion and a
wedding for example are you supposed to look like
a duck that's just come out of water no so it
has nothing to do with it it has to do with
haughtiness so he was addressing haughtiness and
nothing else then the last question about beat
all music has rhythm and it
has melody and it has harmony
and the highest level of music is the harmony
then it has lyrics and all of this comes together
to make a song now a beat a beat can be used
appropriately and it can be used inappropriately
the chances that it would be used inappropriately
increase especially in certain societies where
this is customary and beat was traditionally
used to [Music] activate the lao the lesser gods
in other words it was used in pagan worship to
create a state of consciousness and so beat is
a problem especially when it becomes to syncopated
beat you can use beat without drums you can build
a beat into into the song that you're playing
with your instruments and that sets the rhythm
but to use drums to accentuate it runs the
risk of going into an opposite direction and
now the question is what is heavenly music
like i assume that heavenly music is soft
melodious well articulated harmony obviously if
you have an angelic host singing together there
will be harmony and those are the the elements
of the music that we should strive for and
elevate in our worship okay thank you what if a
person wants to be baptized but doesn't want to
join an organized church will jesus
accept him if he is not a church member
is it appropriate for him to ask a pastor to
baptize him but tell the pastor he doesn't want
to be a member all right actually the first part
of the question is the crux of the matter right
so what if a person wants to be baptized but
he doesn't want to join an organized church
he wants to remain independent well if you are
baptized you are baptized into the body of christ
and what is the body of christ and who is the
body of christ you must follow the biblical
criteria okay so it depends on the light
that you have the time of ignorance god
winks out so if you have come to the
realization that you need to be baptized
but you do not understand the other issues
god accepts that as your best effort right
if you have new light sometimes it
becomes appropriate to baptize again poor
re-baptized people that had received the baptism
of john but hadn't understood the implications of
the gospel message and so they were baptized again
with the understanding that jesus was the messiah
but they were baptized into his organized church
when paul was converted on the way to damascus
where was he sent to the church to the church
jesus could have given him the instructions and
his marching orders right there and then
but he didn't and that is our example he
referred them to the organized church so when
you are baptized you are also baptized into
the body of christ which means you accept
the church his church now in the end time
what are the criteria it's there that keep the
commandments of god hold to the testimony of jesus
etc there's a long list in revelation of
what the end time church will look like
and that is the body that you would
want to be baptized into so yes
a person cannot just be baptized without
being baptized into the body of christ
and therefore is it appropriate for him to
ask a pastor to baptize him but he doesn't
want to be a member if he understands the
implications then it's not an appropriate
thing to do and if he asks to be baptized then
the pastor will explain to him the pastor should
explain to him what it means to be baptized
into the death and resurrection of christ
and to be baptized into the body because if you
go to the book of revelation it says the spirit
and the bride say come because god does not work
independently of his church his body yeah that's
also an interesting point god he also doesn't work
independently in in heaven no he's got councils
he's not a tyrant yeah no he has a council
and we know that that there were councils
where all the representatives came together
we know this from the book of job and there
are elders in heaven so there is a hierarchy and
there is a council god is not a tyrant thank you
please explain the name jesus is
it the name of the messiah or is it
yeshua well that is another bone of contention
we have to go again back into the scriptures
the original new testament both from the internal
evidence and the external evidence was written in
greek and the greek was not a translation it
was written in greek now many of the names
were from hebrew origin and some were
aramaic and these were then translated
or transliterated if you want into greek so for
example peter his name was kefas which was aramaic
but translated it was petros which means stone
all right so was it legal and was it right
for them to take the name kafus and translate it
into the greek and make it petros obviously yes
because they did it right or let's take we
have found messiah which is the hebrew word
then the bible will say translate it
christos and thereafter use the name christos
so was it legal to take a hebrew concept
word like messiah and turn it into the
greek equivalent which is chris christos and
the answer is yes because they did it right
the same applies to the name that we use for jesus
it is yeshua in the old testament and that is the
hebrew version but the bible itself uses the
word yesus now exactly how that was pronounced
is another issue but it was legal to
change it from joshua to yesus now if
you use another language can you then change
that name as well obviously yes so let's say
in german if you read the gospel of john it will
be johannes also in afrikaans it would be johannes
but in english it's john and everybody knows that
is exactly the same person the one is just the
english version and the other one is
the other language right correct so why
is it not essential therefore that i use the
name yeshua is it wrong to use the name yeshua
no you're just using the hebrew version but if
you're not a hebrew you are a greek can you then
use jesus the answer is yes now if you are english
can you use jesus yes then it becomes english
now some people will say okay but originally there
was no jay everything was a y yes that is correct
but language is also progressive and if you go
back into the scripture if you see where jesus
is speaking aramaic for example where he's on
the cross and he says my my father why have you
forsaken my god my god why have you forsaken me
he's using aramaic language but the dialect that
he is using is different from the dialect
that you find for example in the book of
daniel so it's progressive change and it was
legal for him to do it because he himself did it
so when a language changes they brought in the
letter j and many people are unhappy about that
because of the the sound that it implies
everything was a why and you had to
from the word use the pronunciation for
that particular word so if you said yes
that would be with a y right it was a
ye sound but if you say joon it is a j
sound it was also spelt with a y now if you're a
foreigner you will say excuse me why is that why
are they both spelled with a y if they one is
pronounced ye and the other one is pronounced
so in english to emphasize the the pronunciation
as a just sound they introduced the letter
j now is that changing a name and saying
well now you've messed with the name
no you are running with the rules of a language
yes so i always give the example if i go to poland
there my name is volterra but i'm not volterra
i'm walter but i'm actually not walter because i'm
german i'm actually walter so which one is it now
well if i'm in poland i'm a volterra and if i am
in german i'm a walter and if i am in england or
any other english-speaking language i'm a walter
and i must just live with that because that's
the way languages work the same with the bible
so i think there is absolutely nothing wrong by
referring to jesus as jesus just like if i was
speaking greek i would refer to him as yesus and
if i was a hebrew i would speak to him as yeshua
thank you very much would you teach us please how
why and who came up with the modern theology of
revelation that you mentioned many of our brethren
are taught this modern futurist version in their
churches and are certain that it is the gospel
truth yes it is a very strange fact of history
that people can change their understanding
even if it is on solid ground
now if you study your scripture there is no doubt
that prophecy is presented historic continuous
take the book of daniel if you go to daniel
chapter 2 daniel chapter 7 there's a historic
continuous progression through time you start
with babylon you go to the media persian empire
you go to the greek empire you go to the roman
empire you go into the papal roman empire that is
the progression through time if you take the book
of revelation and you take the seven churches the
same pattern applies there is a historic
progression through time if you take the
book of daniel and you go to chapters 8 and 9
you have these beautiful messianic prophecies
where you also have a historic progression
you start with from the issuing of the decree
to restore and rebuild jerusalem this is in
daniel chapter 9 then you go unto messiah
the prince and you have a historic progression
of the events that will take place that is
how scripture should be interpreted and
that is how exegetes used to interpret it
within the protestant world yes so when they
determined the nature of the antichrist system
daniel was the key and martin luther referred
to the book of daniel as a book that everybody
should read so that they have the key which
opens up the rest of prophecy and opens up
the book of revelation that's why martin luther
took the book of daniel and translated it first
and it was historic continues and it pointed out
the progression and the rise of the antichrist and
it was absolutely plain we did a whole what's
up on that so we don't have to repeat that
study it's absolutely plain that the
antichrist system exists from the fall of rome
unto the second coming of christ now they take
that same prophecy and twist it around divest
it from its context throw one week into
the future with no progression whatsoever
make a time prophecy where you use a day for the
year literal with no biblical support whatsoever
and come up with a futuristic idea of a futuristic
antichrist now where do these ideas come from
they are counter-reformation ideas pre-terrorism
futurism the jesuits okaza and ribera came up with
those systems they were refined later by cardinal
bellamine another jesuit to take the heat of the
progressive prophecy and the clear depiction of
rome as the antichrist and to throw it into the
future when the church is not even concerned with
it because it's supposedly raptured away which
again contradicts the very tenet of scripture
the hebrews were not removed from the planet by
a rapture during the plagues they were there that
is the type the antitype will be exactly the same
they were not removed from the tyranny of pharaoh
they were subjected to it there will be no
rapturing and only those that don't live up will
be subjected to it no you have to be consistent
when it comes to scriptural interpretation
so these modern theologies come from the
roman catholic jesuit stable and they have been
infiltrated into the churches either indirectly
or directly yes so that the whole world has come
to accept them as the norm all they have to do
is go and study what the reformers wrote go and
take that book romanism and the reformation if
you want to know what the reformers believed or
go and study what martin luther said on the issue
go and take the book table talk and read it
again there was a war against that book for a
reason and there was a death penalty over anyone
who had it so it must be excellent to read right
so go and study what the reformers believe
then you will not be deceived by this
excuse me nonsense of futurism and prophetic
interpretation that violates every rule in the
bible we've also in episode 33 showed how jonathan
khan and those people that were at the mall
have this same futuristic they have the same
futuristic discussion it's not biblical thank
you next question please address the one saved
always saved belief that is popular on youtube
there's no such thing as once saved always
saved if you take the book of ezekiel
if you go and read chapter 33 or anyone you
will see that the bible is very clear if the
righteous man turns from his righteousness and
does what is evil in the sight of the lord none
of his former righteousness will be remembered
he will surely die referring to eternal death yes
if the unrighteous man turns from his
unrighteousness and does what is right
none of his former unrighteousness will
be remembered that's the good news yes
because it applies to all of us because all
have sinned and fall short of the glory of god
now so can a righteous man turn from his
righteousness yes absolutely he can turn from his
righteousness and then he is no longer righteous
so how do we know where we stand on this issue
how are you saved you're saved by the
blood of the lamb you're saved by faith
in the blood of the lamb so you accept
the sacrifice of jesus christ as your
atonement that is your justification
what is the evidence of justification
sanctification oh yeah you will stop doing what
you did before exactly you move away from it
it will stop if a righteous man turns from his
righteousness none of his former righteousness
will be remembered but if an unrighteous man turns
from his unrighteousness and does what is right
then none of his former unrighteousness will be
remembered so right doing is part of the equation
it doesn't justify you the blood of christ and
the atoning sacrifice justifies you it is an
alien righteousness it is an imputed righteousness
but sanctification is an imparted righteousness
it becomes part of your nature to one to do the
will of god now when you decide you want to do
the will of god you enter into a warfare yes
and that warfare is with self that old man who
refuses to die so every day when you get up in the
morning you take a club which is the word of god
and you clobber him to death and you remind
him that he no longer has any right to exist
because you have been washed and you do not want
to like peter says return like a pig to its wallow
and be full of mud or like a dog to
his vomit you don't want to do that
so there's no such thing in the bible as once
saved always saved i die daily says paul this
is a constant warfare and eventually that which is
very hard becomes habitual and god brings you into
situations where you realize who and what you
really are so to think that you are the bee's
knees and that you are now saved perpetually is
nothing short of presumption it is a daily walk
with christ yes because if it was one saved always
saved israel would have never heard the words that
jesus told them exactly your house is left to you
desolate yes they would have been perfect right no
problem so now this is uh it's a narrow road but
it is the road of righteousness my logic tells me
that to walk in harmony with god's commandments
is logical yeah it is not only love to god it
is respect and love for the neighbor as well
and where i am not in harmony with his will
which is like a mirror that i look at myself
and i see whoa i'm skew here and i'm skewed
there and i need honing there and i have
character defects here and there and i
work on them so at any particular moment while
i am in my sphere striving to do what is right
i'm covered by the righteousness of christ when i
go my own way here and i reject it and i turn from
the righteous walk well then i cannot
expect to be covered by the grace of christ
thank you i just want to bring it in
because you mentioned baptized earlier
some they also link this once you've been baptized
you're now saved and baptism is not a ma it's not
a magic one baptism is a public acknowledgement of
a decision that has been made by a conscious mind
do you believe with your whole heart then you may
be baptized so you have to believe with your whole
heart and give a public display and
acknowledgement of an inner faith that is
what god requires of us and once you have done
that then the warfare starts it doesn't end it
doesn't end because that is when the walk also
starts with god your biggest enemy is yourself
and god allows us to come into tight places
so that your old self can be revealed
even to you and you can also have
loving people that will remind you
of your defects so that you can either rise
up like a mushroom against them or you can
think about it and say yeah okay i need to change
lord help me to do that amen okay next question
what would have happened if
adam and eve never sinned
that's a very loaded question it has a there's
a very deep uh theology associated with this
question so then you have to explain and
elaborate on that all right first the first
question you have to ask is why were adam and
eve created in the first place yes all right was
there a problem in heaven when adam and eve were
created yes yes because god warned adam and eve
of an enemy right yes so there was an enemy
so there had been a tumultuous upheaval in
heaven and there had been a war in heaven and the
devil and these angels had been cast out okay now
there were two sides in this argument the devil
yeah and his angels and god and his angels yes
those were the two sides now in any dispute
when you have a dispute of this nature
you have to have an independent judiciary
to determine who's right and who's wrong now
in human terms if you have a dispute with your
neighbor and you will take him to court right
if the dispute becomes big enough that you
can't solve it and then you will have to abide
by the ruling of the independent judiciary
now if you if you choose a jury for example
then the jury may not be related to you you're
not going to choose your father and your mother
it's not going to be to be on that jury
right or your uncle or your aunt or
your sister or your brother or your best
friend for that matter no it has to be an
independent judiciary now here was a problem
because there was no independent judiciary it was
god and his angels and it was the devil and
his angels now who is right in this dispute
now god being god is the only one who could
solve this problem and so in order to solve
this problem he created a new order of being
that had not been part and parcel of the dispute
and like in any jury or any legal case both sides
get to represent themselves or to present their
arguments in favor of this that or the other
right now the one who created adam and eve
jesus was the one who created him because by him
all things were created and without him nothing
was created so jesus as the creator created adam
and eve and he created them different to all the
others he created the male and female in other
words they had the capacity to bring forth life
just like god had the capacity to bring
forth life and he gave them an independent
mini cosmos and he gave them rulership in
other words he set up an independent judiciary
and they were to be the key the solution
to the problem okay they were the ones who
in the final analysis had to say which of the
two parties was correct and which one was false
so god got first shot to state his case and he
explained to them that he was the creator god
and he had an opportunity to talk to them and
angels had an opportunity to talk to them and then
the other one had got an opportunity at the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil and he stated
his case but he did it in a different way yes
that should have been a warning from the beginning
right and he said did god say did he really say
that so he questioned everything just like in a
case of law when you have the opposite party the
the advocate he will counter the argument and say
did you just say that and this and the
the other what if it were like this right
so you have this this case and the independent
jury is adam and eve they weren't part of the
conflict in heaven they hadn't existed yet
and there was no other way to create an
independent judiciary other than to create
it so god had to create it because the devil
couldn't create it he has no capacity to do that
correct so adam and eve were not an afterthought
they were the solution to the problem now
had they done what they were asked to do
had they investigated the issue and taken time
to study the case of the one argument versus
the other argument the other one said this
god that you are talking to is depriving you
he's lying to you he's a liar did he
really say that you shouldn't touch this
look at me i'm touching it nothing's happening
to me look at me you say it's not good for food
i'll give you an example i'll take a bite and look
what i can do i'm just a snake and i can even talk
so this is very good by the way he's
holding back on you you will be as gods
and the rest is history they chose sides
and then they suffered the consequences
yes which is a logical thing right exactly and so
we have a planet of rebellion now that didn't end
there because god even in this situation offered
his help in a way out by promising a messiah
and in a sense man is still
a judicial system determining
who is right and who is wrong in this argument
from one generation to the next generation and our
generation now has an opportunity to judge between
what god says here it is and it's very open
and you can question many of the things that
happened in the descriptions in this book
and you can read the occult books and you can
find out what the other side of the story is
so we're still a judiciary
now what that's a long intro
this is fine but now what would have
happened if adam and eve had not sinned
well then the jury would have sat and the jury
would have given their verdict and the devil and
his host would have been subject to that verdict
correct and if the wages of sin is death as god
had proclaimed and adam and eve as an independent
judiciary had come to the conclusion that the only
way to deal with this is by the executive judgment
the wages of sinner's death then the devil and
his angels would have been eliminated and there
would have been peace and harmony in the universe
and this is where we're heading well it's
going to come again yes there will be
this final decision again do you not know that you
will judge angels does the bible say that yes yes
so again there will be a judicial system and
humanity will be very involved because the book
of revelation tells us that judgment was handed
to the saints so god is as judged has given a
judgment judgment is handed to the saints they go
through the books and they determine whether that
judgment is fair or not that's what a judiciary
does and then they will say just and fair
are your judgments and worthy is the lamb that
will be the final decision and then there will be
a destruction of the devil and his angels and the
wicked and the universe will be cleansed of all
unrighteousness of course you can
take this argument even further now
because there was another
opportunity god chose the people
he chose the israelites and he brought
them into connection with himself yes
and he gave them good judgments and
he told them his side of the story
and he explained from sinai his law and he
explained in great detail why it was essential
that all humanity should be subject to this law
right so god stated his case and then there were
the pagan nations all around yeah that stated
the other case what did they choose unfortunately
they made no better choices than adam and eve
had done so let's just go with this and say
what if theoretically what if theoretically they
had accepted and not rejected jesus as the messiah
then what would have happened then
they would not have crucified him right
they would have but the wages of sin is death and
humanity had sinned and humanity needed redemption
and without the shedding of blood there's
no forgiveness of sin so the messiah would
have to die but if his people were not
prepared to kill him but accepted him
as the righteous one and the rightful ruler
of the universe then the only story we have
in the bible is that of abraham and isaac
and abraham was the one who was to sacrifice
isaac and at the last moment god stayed his
hand and said no i have a substitute for you
a type that serves as the type for the great
antitype the messiah will come and will die in
your stead then i think that the father would
have enacted the role and would have slain the son
and the son having life within himself
would have been raised from the dead and
then we wouldn't have had this terrible drama
that we had before and the nation of israel
would have become the kingdom of god and anybody
who did not want to join it would suffer the same
consequence as those who refuse and that
would have solved the problem so basically
what i'm saying is humanity is the solution to the
sin problem now they can't solve the sin problem
only god can solve the sin problem but they act as
the independent judiciary as to the righteousness
of god's judgments yes and the plan has also not
changed yet no because israel yeah israel did not
live up to what they should have known so now
we've gone 2 000 years later the story is not
changed exactly we still have the spiritual israel
that is supposed to do all of this and eventually
when jesus comes back and eventually
there will only be a remnant of a remnant
that will eventually stick with the plan
and say no god's judgments are righteous
and they're just and that's how it will pan out
thank you very much what is the difference between
seventh the adventists and seventh-day reformed
adventists you are loading the questions here
um is this a question that you received
yeah this is just the questions that i
receive and okay what is the difference between
an adventist and a seventh-day reform adventist
well the original church that arose out of the
great disappointment in the millerite movement
eventually was the seventh-day adventist church
who realized that god's commandments were binding
and that christ was indeed going to come but
that that misunderstood the the sanctuary element
of the message christ wasn't going to come at
that time to restore the earth he was going into
the next phase of the ministry in the heavenly
sanctuary and once that was completed he would
return that's the seventh-day ad move adventist
movement it had a a beginning and it will continue
to the end now just like israel of all is
this a perfect church no don't shake your
head so violently what's wrong with you you
should be standing up for them and saying yes
well you you mentioned earlier all
levels short to the glory of god okay
they're not perfect we're not perfect no
no in fact if you want to listen let's not
go there some of us are just less perfect than
others and some of them make a determined effort
to try and be less perfect than others all right
so this church has its ups and downs and it has
the wheat in it and it has tears in it and the
wheat and the tears will remain for how long
until the end okay are there decisions that
they make always of the highest standard no
unfortunately not no their decisions aren't
always of the highest standard could some within
the ranks be upset with some of the decisions
that are sometimes made definitely or some of
the examples that are said yes this is part of
human nature it's the part of the fallen nature
so what happened was the reform
adventists in germany in particular
they were extremely disheartened
and upset when the church basically
capitulated to the power of the nazi regime
by allowing [Music] adventists to take up arms
and some of them separated themselves
from the body now what they actually did
is they voiced their concern about a
decision and separate it themselves
but the bible clearly says that this body
with its faults and with its idiosyncrasies
will continue until the end and then there will be
a shaking so what the bible actually tells us then
is that you should agitate for
righteousness and reform within the body
until the shaking which is something that
god does takes place and my opinion is
that even though their their reasons might have
been perfectly legitimate the separation was not
in harmony with what the scriptures teach about
the situation after all the scriptures give a
pretty clear indication of what the state
of the church is yes it is poor it is blind
it is wretched it is naked it needs i solve and
it better buy some gold refined in the fire or
else it will be spewed out of the mouth right
not a very good description of the final church
so it's not difficult to say well
i don't want to be with this bunch
well if you take daniel he was part of that
bunch he suffered the consequences he was taken
and led to babylon he was put into the most dire
circumstances he was thrown to the lions you
mention it his friends were thrown into the fiery
furnace why because they stood for what was right
okay and what about their church didn't they cause
it by their decisions and by their their wrong
decisions and by their stubbornness yep well it's
not going to be any different here at the end paul
why was he imprisoned in jerusalem exactly
his own church his own church created the
circumstances that led to his demise but he
didn't separate himself so this final body
will go through to the kingdom and god is going
to shake it so don't shake yourself beforehand
there's another question that comes
up to me now that um the shaking is
a question that i heard that why how do you know
the shaking is not to be out of the church but in
the shaking means you're not you're shaking out if
you're shaking something well actually if you take
the example that that god uses is the threshing
floor yes there's pretty much of a shaking going
on in the threshing floor but what remains in the
threshing from the threshing floor is the wheat
yes what is blown away is the chaff
now i've had many occasions when reform
adventists have spoken to me and they are very
nice people amongst the reform adventists as well
but i've consistently told them that
they should come to the main body
and why should i suffer alone in this body
come and join us so one of them once said
to me but it stinks in the body and i
said yes but get yourselves a clothespin
and put it on your nose
because these are the circumstances that will
exist until christ comes until this shaking
takes place and finally you will have a remnant
of a remnant that will proclaim the three angels
messages in power and not invariants as we have
it today in many many cases yes and that's maybe
you can also just and say um encourage
meant yes don't don't lose courage and uh
yes stay within the body i would say put glue put
glue stay within the body until the shaking has
even if it looks like the ship is sinking yeah it
will go through to the kingdom there's a iceberg
ahead and we're going to hit it and uh well we'll
bear with those consequences because the captain
is steering the ship towards the iceberg
amen okay can you please explain tithing
tithing tithing is something that irks the
the fallen nature we believe that everything
that we have is from our own doing but the bible
clearly tells us that it is god who enables you
even to attain to riches right and god set up a
system whereby he sustained his church and that
was called tithing and he asked for one-tenth
now there are very few governments in the world
that ask for one-tenth they ask for considerably
more than one-tenth so it is a very fair system
and he said that the tithe that you bring is
for the levite in other words it is to sustain
the preaching of god's word that is what the
tithe is there for other things were to be done
through offerings so if you wanted to expand your
infrastructure that was not to come from the tithe
that was to come from a freewill offering and
you have many examples of that in the bible yes
of free will offerings to rebuild the temple
for example even the tabernacle was built with
offerings not this time and also the original
temples so the tithe was there to sustain
god's work and it is not yours it is actually
god's tithe and it's a it's a it's a concept which
is irking to some people because they feel this
is all mine now i have to give that you have to
change your mindset i once said to one of my sons
who i gave them some pocket money and i told them
that they should give a tithe to the lord of that
i was trying to teach them the tithe principle
and it was very hard for them to do that
yeah so i said to one of my sons one day
i said oh i have a gift for you you were
you were good you were very good and
here is a gift for you and i gave him a certain
amount of money and then i said oh and by the way
here let's let's let's take an example let's say
ten dollars right i said here's a gift for you
i've got nine dollars for you here you have nine
dollars that's yours and i said here is one dollar
uh give this one to your brother and off
he ran and he was so happy and he gave
the one dollar to his brother and he had nine
dollars so i let him stew on that for a while
and then i said to him i called him and i
said did you give did you give that dollar to
that wasn't a dollar it was south african country
but that is irrespective is this the story did
you give that dollar to your brother he said yes i
said did you have a problem giving him the dollar
he said no i said why didn't you have
a problem giving your brother a dollar
he says it was just one dollar and i said how much
did you get they said i've got nine [Laughter]
so i said so you're very happy with your nine
and you're very happy that your brother only
got one right you didn't get nine he says yeah
i thought it was kind of cool i got nine and
he only got one i said uh-huh so why did you
give him that dollar he says but it wasn't mine
it was his yeah so i said okay so he
had no problem giving him that dollar
and that's how you must think
about tithing it's not yours
god has given you nine and he's asking you
will you give us one to support my cause
and you should say wow i got nine and you only
want one with pleasure can i give you some
more after all i've got nine here's another one
that should be your your attitude but we want to
judge and we want to say i don't know whether
this is going to be used for the right cause
leave that to god because if the tithe goes
to the levite there are good levites and there
are levites like the sons of eli and
it's not for me to judge who is who
i am supporting the overall work so bring in your
tithe into the storehouse that's my opinion thank
you very much with that i think we can conclude
for this episode thank you for the wonderful
explanations and may god bless the viewers as
they plunder over all of this yes let's pray
heavenly father thank you that you have given us
questioning minds and i know lord that you want us
to ask questions because else you would not have
given us questioning reasoning minds and after all
we had to have questioning reasoning minds
in order to fulfill the role that you gave us
and thank you for the answers that you've given
us in your word where we through study and then
through a reasoning mind determine whether this
is a good path to walk or not choose either's day
is what you say and you also say come let us
reason together thank you lord that you do
not bypass our reasoning capacity and thank
you that we can ask questions and thank you
even more that your word provides the answers
bless us as we walk in our daily walk with you
and make daily decisions as to the path that we
wish to tread we pray this in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video click here thank you